the algorithm is definitely feeding me
death lately you know it's just
algorithms like you want more yeah yeah
one of those four people that died in
that boating yeah Tick Tock challenge
yeah
it's kind of funny like Twitter like
designates how you're gonna feel that
day and it decides yeah every morning I
think someone's programming on the back
end they're like well Noel's gonna be
angry today yeah angry or Noel's gonna
be sad today yeah or like you know
depressed yeah
doomed yep let's like let's give him a
whole bunch of murder [__] yeah yeah
yeah that's why I always say like are
you sad or is it the algorithm yeah
that's so true
it's so [__] true I deleted Twitter
off my phone and it's like I have felt
happy yeah again yeah
like every day I was just starting my
day with this like oh what the [__] is
this guy saying yeah you know what I
mean that's a good feeling
okay
we had to take a quick break because the
computer crashed but I also we shut down
the slot yeah so we could focus yeah
what we were talking about because I was
like is this even legal to have this in
California
and well we're not in California so
it's true we are in space that's a good
point so we're safe up here we're
totally good but yes it would be illegal
to have yes if we were running a covert
slot room yeah which would be like the
way less cool version of a poker room
yeah so instead of that we run a slot
room and it's all senior citizens
that come in and we run it you know we
wear suits and we walk around the we
have just rows of slots yeah and it's
like in a basement somewhere yeah and we
walk around Gladys good to see you and
she's like
hey Cody you know my son-in-law says
okay don't care Beatrice good to see you
if I win I think I might be able to buy
some in some instant yep okay
well then you better keep playing
Beatrice okay keep smacking the button
my hearing aid died last week I haven't
been able to [__] the button
racking the buttons smack the button
smack going it your luck will turn
around just keep playing don't say
please turn around
never mind God
sucks I mind
yeah oh yeah the button keeps smacking
the button exactly
that's what I'll you know and that's how
I'll talk when I hit the floor
yeah I'll be they'll be like no
[Laughter]
no
I'm like ladies ladies one at a time
relax relax relax relax
my partner he's very good with the
button very good the button maybe he'll
come by and smack that one for you
celeb shot oops ah ding oh 30 free spins
look at that and then one of them turns
around Haggard old man
what's his name uh
Clyde Clyde okay he turns around to you
and he's like
you know odd bisexual in college
[Laughter]
for 40 years but I would have [__] the
[__] out of a guy like you
all right Clyde thank you man I
appreciate it you got a great ass champ
okay thank you man
God
and then you turn around and walk away
and he smacks it and he's like well man
got free
hey Clyde you keep that hand on the
button all right hands off the
merchandise all right
and then we take them for all their
worth yeah
to the bottom yeah oh yeah
when the and then when there's an old
person just crying at the machine
does run out that's too bad you're gonna
have to my retirement you have to get
off the chair
we have people waiting there's there's
people in the lobby so we're gonna need
you to bounce slides here you need to
get any kind of a thing
we got a special little things
yeah yeah every time Clyde wins you walk
up behind him your your hand just kind
of hitting his waist a little bit you're
like nice job he's like thanks thanks
form a conspiracy
no Clyde wants to have sex with me
yeah but he turns you around oh okay so
then it's like sort of like uh I yearn
for the attention yes yeah yeah you both
know like you're in relationships yeah
kind of like turn my ass forward you
know yeah
let me check the machine here for you
yeah yeah let me just see his things
plugged in yep it is all plugged in I'm
just checking hey eyes on the eyes on
the slaw machine come on come on keep
playing around
[__] this guy
lock this guy up
[Laughter]
he's in the button you're just around
he's like
you're distracting me again
stop it glass I'm gonna need you to
leave Cody
dude
speaking I I meanwhile with this oh
sorry I'm just gonna say meanwhile be in
the corner and uh someone would be
negotiating me to cut their lawn
yeah yeah exactly you guys do very good
work I don't agree with everything Trump
has to say about you I don't I'm a big
fan of the Mexicans I'm not uh I'm not
sorry I don't speak Spanish
right I'm sorry
no hablo
right not uh not a landscaper
landscapers come in more than one size
and origin
but thank you anyway what were you
saying well I I feel like it's my turn
to Kid Cudi this now because I remember
this when you were talking about just
like I packed a reporter
that's done
no I was thinking about this because
uh you know I was like you were talking
about your depressing story so I was
like what's one that I could bring up
and then I was like wait I've been
thinking about this all morning since
you drove this [__] car in here the
reason why I'm so nervous about carbon
monoxide is because I saw that article
about the two people that died on
vacation
oh yeah you see that in Mexico it's like
a nice five-star hotel
and they both died of carbon monoxide
poisoning because apparently the machine
had been unplugged like four times yeah
run out of batteries and the hotel just
would not replace it
and they just ignored it and then both
of them died this is a five-star hotel
well
yeah
and it's like a Hyatt or something like
that so now they're like being sued to
high heaven obviously now they just
sells five stars
what I don't get it if you play Grand
Theft Auto
oh nice nice
damn just just no I'm just picturing the
game like oh the hotel manager just
standing at the desk and then out of
nowhere just to Five Stars start
blinking she's like what what do we do
yeah so I've just been nervous that
we're gonna die the whole time no it's
cool man
no it's too bad yeah totally yeah
oh [__]